TAKE THE
PIERCING CANES ARE ABLE TO JUMP
ON IT.
>> Tripp: FOR THE MAJORITY OF
AN OPTIONAL MORNING G
THE ICE AND THAT FRONT FOR
CHECK ANDFOR DOMI. IN.
CIRCLING FOU
MONTREAL.
FREDERIKB ANDERSEN, WHAT HE IS
DONE ALL SEASON LONG,.CASH IN T
>> Tripp:
HARD WORK . WHAT A JOB, SLAVIN,
KNOWING ICK, QUICKLAMOTION,EM A
CHANCE TO GO  WAS
SNAPPED ON BYDeANGELO.
HE WILL STEP OVER AND REBOUNDS
REBOUND CHANCE,  ALLEN GETS THE
--. . DOWN LOW ANDPOWERPLAY,
NIEDERREITER  INTO CAROLINA HUR
HIS PASS ALMOST HELPED ,  WORKI
NECAS .>> Tripp: AS
WAS AHEAD,
DVORAK  FINDS HIS WAY BACK UP
A TIP, THE LESS THE PUCK
OH, MY GOODNESS.
JOSH ANDERSON
BECAUSE IT LOOKED LIKE IT WENT
ON PERHAPS, HIS LEFT SKATE AND
JU BY HOFFMAN, REBOUND
CHANCE
>> Tripp: HOFFMAN CAN FIRE THE
EMPTY NET GOAL S WIKIPEDIA
PAGE.
EMPTY NET MAGICIAN